vous connaissez la NBA ça se provoque
sur le terrain
moi j'ai rien dit à côté
j'ai pas touché à sa mère j'ai rien fait
je préfère ta sœur
[Rires]
sur le moment j'ai rien senti mais après
son carton rouge tu t'es pas dit waouh
j'ai sorti Zidane
en fait j'ai mis attendais même pas
c'était dingue
quand j'étais au sol il était hors de
question pour moi que je me relève s'il
ne prenait pas de carton rouge
[Rires]
il était à fond dans le match je joue
avec lui vraiment il était à fond il
était persuadé qu'il pouvait me fourrer
l'histoire est vrai en plus vraiment
l'histoire est vrai il y avait un
traducteur et je lui ai dit la vérité
dit à ton pote c'est pas la peine qu'il
soit à fond frère
donc je m'amuse avec lui je suis sympa
ne m'oblige pas puisque lui mettre moi
aussi un coup de boule
[Applaudissements]
il débute il débute ce jour-là Zidane
avait pété les plombs parce qu'il se
trouve que le jour de la finale ça maman
n'allait pas bien ah c'est ça c'est sa
sœur qui s'occupait justement de sa
maman et toute la journée il avait eu sa
sœur au téléphone pour prendre des
nouvelles de sa maman et quand ma
terrasse dit lui a dit je préfère bien
sûr à ton maillot il a complètement
péter les plombs moi je suis président
il a le droit de faire ça
c'est le meilleur joueur de paddle dans
le foot ça reste Didier Deschamps si
vous regardez mon chéri d'idée des
choses voilà je te le dis mon Didier tu
es le meilleur joueur de paddle dans le
foot et moi bien que vous quand même
est-ce que
vous êtes quitte mais qu'est-ce qu'on
est quitte pas qui du tout mais c'est
quoi Didier tu regardes trois matchs
partout c'est pas qui pour moi c'est moi
qui ai gagné
frère il s'est passé quand même plein de
beaucoup de bois
à ton âge tu progresseras plus ton merde
ah je l'adore c'est mon ami
physiquement il est monstrueux en plus
il a dit qu'elle se prépare
un costume qui a la première fois la
prochaine fois qu'on se rencontre ça
change rien est-ce qu'il est aussi
mauvais joueur que vous oui
alors le problème il s'insulte ah oui
déteste
[Rires]
pardon et c'est un superbe vraiment et
je l'adore mais il est fermé quand il
perd il perd et quand il gagne par
contre il t'appelle beaucoup de fois
après euh non mais vraiment c'est
vraiment un ami et c'est un mec
extraordinaire Didier vraiment je l'aime
vraiment fort
franchement
le problème qu'il a et je le dis voilà
si vous regardez le problème il est bon
physiquement il est bon dans la tête il
a bon il a le latin dans la mais
techniquement techniquement
[Rires]
vous vous n'êtes vous vous êtes moins
bon mais où je suis moins bon
parce qu'il chambre
prochaine fois pense plutôt à jouer
l'autre champagne je rigole ça va c'est
un habit c'est bon
un jour on a fait un match on était tous
les deux ensemble
on jouera plus jamais
on se dit on a joué jeu il jouait très
bien d'ailleurs on a joué les deux
ensemble voilà on s'est fait on va faire
un match on va se mettre tous les deux
ensemble pour une fois vous êtes
disponible
qu'est-ce que tu prends la balle là
pourquoi tu me l'as pas laissé mais toi
c'est toi la chèvre vas-y c'est toi la
chèvre diminue vas-y on jouera plus
jamais tous les noms c'est fini et tu es
une chèvre était une pipe arrête et
partout et retourner jouer au foot et
toi vas-y retourne sur les plateaux télé
ça
a duré c'est bon on a pris 600 600 c'est
terminé on est rentré comme ça allez
l'histoire et l'histoire est belle on a
arrêté Jacqueline je t'ai pas entendu là
bah moi j'adore Zidane évidemment mais
je pense que on paie un joueur aussi
cher pour évidemment son talent mais
aussi pour savoir se maîtriser mais si
parce que il a mis en danger son équipe
en faisant ça et tout un match hyper
important c'est aussi pour tenir ses
nerfs voilà donc je trouve que
en général
donc je te dis et moi je peux comprendre
qu'on est des coups de sang moi ça
m'arrive jamais mais je peux le
comprendre voilà je peux le comprendre
pour la solution
n'arrête pas de leur se disent des trucs
vous savez comment ça se passe
quand tu es en défense quand tu es avec
des gars tu leur dis des trucs dans
l'oreille moi bien sûr ta mère en short
au Franprix
il y a pas ta mère dans les tribunes non
mais c'est vrai
Zidane j'aurais filé le numéro de
téléphone de ma sœur
[Rires]